talk us firstly what is happening in
bhagmat yeah well the for the region
Winter's fast approaching the rains have
arrived and whilst that doesn't stop the
fighting it makes off-road fighting very
difficult for heavy Vehicles so we're
rapidly approaching the position where
life will pause for for the the winter
can't come soon enough for Russian
forces their military is beleaguered
they're being pushed back in so many
areas the one anomaly though is in
mahmut where they are throwing a lot of
forces at the fight there endless
attacks is how um president zielinski
described it it looks like they're using
a lot of their newly formed reservists
and by countless attacks is causing huge
amount of casualties on the Russian side
why are they doing it well it seems
coherent with Putin's aim that it's a
special military operation he always
said he wanted to secure the donbass
region looks like a frantic attempt to
do that before the winter Pours and
looking at the wider situation around
the country where are we yeah but the
Russians are basically the military are
very short of soldiers and they've been
mobilizing the reserve Force about three
hundred thousand so the challenge is how
do you assimilate into that that into
the fighting you can't use these
reservists as Standalone units because
they wouldn't have any leadership or
experience so they've got to be used to
augment existing units one of the
existing units is the Army is a company
it's a hundred people traditionally some
of the Russian units are down to six to
eight people of that hundred that's all
that survived so it's a clear indication
of how they need to bolster the number
when we're in kharkive where the
Ukraine's liberated car key if the
Russians left a whole load of secret
documents there and they exposed the
Dreadful state of the combat
Effectiveness so the Russian forces down
at 11 huge problems with morale and also
Logistics so the Russian Folks at the
moment is to try and transition these
300 000 people into the front line
largely going from offense to defense
that's a pragmatic solution because
these new soldiers are not well equipped
they're not well trained and they
certainly don't have Battlefield
experience they're only really useful in
defense that downside of that of course
is on a military perspective you only
Prevail on the battlefield with a
combination of initiative and momentum
as soon as you dig defensive positions
you are predictable and you are static
that hands the initiative to ukrainians
and I've no doubt Ukraine will seek to
capitalize
what make you of reports of potential
support coming for Russia from Belarus
yeah from a geographic perspective
Belarus and Ukraine obviously have a
fairly extensive border here and if I
was trying to attack the seat of parrot
Kiev I'd rather do that from Belarus
than I would from Russia but lukashenko
has been a puppet obviously leader of
Belarus been a puppet of the Putin
regime for some time the Belarusian Army
is only about 15 000 strong and to be
brutally honest Putin needs that's not
hundreds of thousands it's not tens of
thousands and also a lot of equipment
but it's an interesting relationship
between these two so one example of that
is that whilst we're suffering from high
energy prices in the west Putin is
providing lukashenko with gas at five
percent of the market price clearly
trying to keep lukashenko sweet but on
the flip side ninety percent of the
Belarusian population do not want to get
involved in this war so it's a real
tightrope if Putin fails lukashenko
probably fails what looks most likely is
that whilst um Belarus probably won't
get involved directly in the fighting
they're definitely going to be enabling
and supporting Putin's wider Ambitions
and you mentioned that the for the
Russians the winter can't come soon
enough how do you see the next few
months playing out yeah it's very
difficult because ultimately this is
Putin's plan it's very difficult for us
as analysts to work out exactly where
he's going with this for example a week
ago we're watching heavy equipment leave
hellson to the west of the country
expecting the Russian forces to move out
now it appears they're bolstering those
forces and digging in ready for a long
fight what we can say is the Russian
military is spent that they are digging
in but as to their future Ambitions we
have to try and get inside Putin's head
and one of the ways of doing that is
listening to his speeches he did a
speech of the valdi discussion club uh
only the uh only the other day and this
is what interfacts have reported the
fact that Russians of Ukraine is a
fundamentally one people is a historical
fact and been ripped apart for
historical
that plays well to a domestic audience
but it's completely incongruous with the
actions of the Russian military on the
ground that are flattening Ukrainian
cities devastated communities stacking
up loads of Civilian casualties along
the way definitely not the actions of a
liberating Force